or so welcome to the very unexpected
part 2 of the February Journal Captain's
Log supplemental
so I was just editing part 1 I was like
wow this is so long out so what we left
off was Vanessa just moved in and I'm
about to do a review for happy deathday
to you I believe this is actually on
Valentine's Day which Vanessa's
sentiment on Valentine's Day is the same
as mine which is don't give a [ __ ] so
just dish it around the house but I'm
about to do my review and here we go
let's go back alright I totally have to
do this review happy deathday to you
because vanessa has just moved in and
she's she's allocating things to places
she's unpacking boxes the place is
getting worked over which is fine and
great but uh she's doing all of it and I
still have to do this review so I need
to finish this so I can get done with
this so I can help her unpack boxes so
she doesn't unpack all the boxes because
nothing shittier than having to unpack
all your [ __ ] while your boyfriend
doesn't help you I know so if you're
watching this I'm really trying to hurry
I swear when filming always check to see
how much space is left on your SD card
because nothing breaks your momentum
then your camera saying card fall while
you're filming all right so let's dump
the memory off this and we'll do the
second half of the happy deathday to you
review happy deathday tu review is up
and now which is it weird that I just
noticed that we've decided to do
Valentine's Day chores which means we do
have to find places I don't want to show
my messy-ass kit they'll be like you're
a [ __ ] slob we'll be like no it's
because it's moving inside stops people
moving in and Vanessa moving in and all
that stuff is is it but the inner light
like smart ones
it's the observant people will be like
that shit's been there for weeks you can
tell by this like oh [ __ ] they're right
yeah 1 2 3 4 bits
Furniture Arndt's we need to find places
for them I guess I mean I'm fine with it
just being here know what I like about
it is the obstacle course it's a living
room I feel like it's an extra workout
to my day
all right here we'll uh I'll show them
all that [ __ ] and all that [ __ ] all
right yeah you know it is a little messy
and it's far enough away they don't know
my place is usually messy but it's not
that mess is new so maybe it does exist
these side pieces don't exist whatever
happened I noticed those days later it's
daily vlog
we must I must yeah as I eat a banana
this is really a bit of information as I
woke up with the Disney Afternoon theme
stuck in my head and I don't know why
I haven't heard that theme in years or
days you're so funny enough I had it
Genesis but I've never played contra
hardcore and so I just got contra
hardcore it's so now we get to play it
and all accounts say I'm gonna hate
myself because it's supposedly like the
impossible contra game like the hardest
contra game but we'll see but first I
mean we gotta open the game up make sure
I didn't get ripped off on eBay that's
also important okay yeah it's good
didn't look like a repro everything
looked really legit but I mean you gotta
know for sure and this is Saturday as
one Saturday the princess has repented
the castle and we were just cooking so
she's kind of scared cuz you get scared
of this stuff danger on the other hand
he doesn't care as they wait for my
friends to come over I'm playing out of
this world or another world rather watch
I just run over and this guy's gonna
grab me and kick my [ __ ] dick in
[Music]
there's a life of me I don't know how
anyone can beat this game without a game
genie yep
I used to game genie to B contri
hardcore because [ __ ] it I'm pretty sure
the difficulty in this game was created
as a joke or a dare it's [ __ ]
impossible without one
however beat this one legit so you know
good day so we have to get the cats and
the dogs used to each other you're gonna
get the cats used to this place first to
the dogs sleep downstairs and at dawn
every morning this is the music watch
you fight the swampthing oh you just
beat up the swamp thing oh this one
thing like that is Mechagodzilla how did
someone knock it sued I was one supposed
to complete this monochromatic cat with
those pieces and years it's allergy day
again there nailed it so complete
I have tissue in my nose that's why I
sound weird goddess elegy days gone from
bad to worse like it was bad and now
it's really bad so I display it to the
store get some allergy meds hopefully
they bring back from the precipice of
madness and that clothes I already took
one I'm not close to just crushing it up
and snorting more at my nose but I
supposed to be date night tonight so uh
oh my god if anyone's wondering what
allergies feel like you know that
feeling you get when you're in a
swimming pool with chlorine and some
chlorine gets up your nose and it burns
it's like that all day
so it was date night and while we were
there because I had hardcore allergy
attack as you saw and it started to get
better and I was like I don't think we
have to cancel let's go to date night
push it back yeah we pushed it back from
5:00 to 7:00 the reservation yeah and
like the whole time my face is puffy and
I'm like my nose is gross and and I was
being obnoxious like are you having a
good time it was just I was sneezing and
yeah it was just terrible but you know
we we got all the food we were like can
we get this into go bags and boxes too
that we have to go and a slice of key
lime pie to go because I have to if you
hear sounds that sound like a TomTom
it's actually just a little danger and
so that was date night my advice is if
you're having a hard core allergy attack
just power through cancel just just feel
like you know what we're gonna stay home
today and we will do it another night
because we have left the work out this
is such a week for meal prepping at
midnight she was tired cuz she was up
all night
barking keeping us up yeah that's right
gypsy okay so admittedly I'm late to the
game on this one I've spent most of my
life single in fact Venice is the first
girlfriend I've had live with me so I
just recently figured this out but I
figured I'd pass it on to you in case
you don't know yet when you get up in
the morning and when you make yourself
breakfast if your girlfriend says oh no
I'm good I'll get something later
she ain't good and she's gonna get your
food at least some of your food so what
you need to do is when you dish your
food dish about 25 percent more food
than you would actually eat at least so
when she picks at your food you still
get 100 percent of what you would eat
it's it's survival at this point because
I definitely got about 25 percent less
food today
also always finish it off with a
compliment so Vanessa if you're watching
pretty and smart and wonderful and
determined or I'm just gushing about my
girlfriend now point is dish yourself
more food so now having cats because who
needs clean towels yeah I got to turn on
my light there you go
God know people are looking at me just
vlogging you know the moment you arrive
somewhere where you arrive too early to
go in but too late to go to the mall and
do anything just got to sit in your car
like an [ __ ] that's what I'm doing
about to watch How to Train Your Dragon
3 as I'm sitting in my car okay so this
is Keita
and that's Ramsay perfectly said thought
to film my review for fighting with my
family I'm totally gonna give this thing
awesome tacular which I feel like people
are gonna be like two in a row for the
same week that's crazy but I just really
did it this movie's inspiring and I
needed a movie like that right now is uh
I know some people might think it's
weird I think it's pretty fantastic cuz
I'm at a pretty good time at the movies
or so I'm editing my review of fighting
with my family right now and in my
review I say it's a drama first and
foremost but it has comedy in it and on
the poster it says a comedy not a drama
I don't get [ __ ] for that who knows
maybe I'll cut it out maybe I'll keep it
anyone know how to get a cat out from
under a dresser there's a my walk-in
closet I can't leave her here come on
kita I don't speak dogs it's easy just
throw a Kong or something it's fine so
Vanessa gave danger and JIP say some cat
food once off of the spoon and now
whenever she's at the sink it's it's
this all the time
my god the receipts anymore get returned
him oh [ __ ] my name is Jeremy Jones it's
been one week since Vanessa moved in
which means the cats have been here for
seven days which means it's been one
week since I've gotten a good night's
sleep around
it's crazy I've never seen anything like
it the first couple days it was actually
[ __ ] in danger downstairs who would
bark at 3:00 a.m. we got that under
control so they don't do that anymore
but then he's like hey you know what
since dogs aren't doing it
maybe I'll just [ __ ] with you they're
actually they're sweet cats but you see
them see him storing that energy right
now
he's just storing that energy he's gonna
unleash it like it's a limit break in
Final Fantasy seven about 3:00 or 4:00
a.m. last night it was 5:00 a.m. and I
just woke up sleep is very key to store
that energy I'm gonna need it wake me up
4:00 a.m. I should have a personal bet
with myself as to what pair of animals
are gonna wake us up first
gypsy in danger the dogs or kita and
Ramsey the cats
I think [ __ ] in danger because I saw
[ __ ] drink water and it was too soon
for her to be able to pee before we went
to bed so fellow she's gonna have to pee
in the night she's in our kennel which
means 5:00 a.m. here we come so it was a
double win last night the cats woke me
up an hour after I went to sleep the
dogs woke me up at 6:00 a.m. so I feel
like the cats get the prize but they
both share the prize we're going to dare
I say a cabin in the woods this is how
freaked my dogs get when they're in cars
you can't see it but he's majestic
Patrick Swayze rides it on a board this
barks ear-piercing that's how much we
have that much gas left two miles
gas stations right up here I think it's
less than two months away so we arrived
at the cabin the cabin in the woods
if you guys don't find me it's because I
elected to just stay here forever
or an axe murderer took me out it
possibly took my kidney okay good
friends and games you can hear them
upstairs we're nothing no technology no
comments no videos can hit us until we
get back and plug into the Wi-Fi just
friends and snow ain't girlfriend which
you are friend you know what I mean well
I'm taking video for the journal that we
made a snowman next to a lake that we
definitely shouldn't step out on but we
didn't step out on it so this is exactly
what's gonna come to life tonight and
kill us all in our sleep and he's gonna
be like her birthday whoa I just said my
first word we uh we gave him hair and he
immediately looks more stressed out
given the fact that this is all we had
to work with like I like that he has
eyebrows I've never seen a snowman with
eyebrows we did good today by Adam made
him a cat not a dog but you know no
matter what age you are you still have
to [ __ ] with ice even if it's a frozen
like that you could fall in I'm flipping
a coin as to whether or not I'm about to
be single not by choice but because I'm
about to lose a girlfriend by snowman
and snow cat you keep it real
go on adventures cabin vacation with
friends it's coming to an end there's a
great get together it's great seeing
everybody and hanging out I had a good
time but now back to reality back from
the trip back from hanging out now we
get to relax in the got a clean room
that's a disaster it has been for how
long has it been
wake and a half so we're back from
vacation with our friends hung out with
them all weekend it was a lot of fun to
hang out with them because it's hi Rams
a high of a cat on my lap now that was
unexpected for this video hold on so I
had to remove a cat from my lap so uh
picked up the puppies they're back we're
all back and the Oscars for today and
he's it was one of the things where I
just I just didn't care this year cuz
they asked just for me they're always a
fun thing to place best with your
friends or who's gonna win this or that
but past that I feel there's very little
reason for me to watch because I'm not
connected with the Academy's mindset I I
don't think like the Academy I generally
don't think like critics I don't think
like the whole of Hollywood and in this
I didn't get I didn't start my YouTube
channel to start thinking like them you
know I started my youtube channel
because I was like I don't think like
that world maybe there are other people
like me who like movies you love to talk
about movies but don't think like that
and so I have to remember that's why I
started my channel I didn't start my
channel to start playing in that sandbox
I started my channel because there were
other people who played in a different
sandbox the same sandbox I played in so
yes this year I was just like among all
the drama and weird [ __ ] story with the
Academy Awards this shows that they're
just a bunch of out of touch people who
want to be in touch but the more they
try to be in touch the poor it's obvious
they're out of touch so this year I just
didn't give a [ __ ]
Vanessa and I worked on stuff around the
house and that was that so I can always
Google the winners if I want to another
day and that well I guess I don't go
every day but at the therapist again
which is funny because this is the first
the second time you're saying this is
the first month you're saying this
I didn't just start going this month I
actually did
make a journal entry last month in
January to show you a I'm at the
therapist and I recorded the whole thing
but there was this weird dancing hair on
my face it was like this rogue dog hair
and it just was like I can't look past
it
it's gonna annoy me so I just didn't
have that in there I was like I'll just
film one next month so here we are at
the therapist let's talk about some [ __ ]
therapy went well it was a lot of fun
it's always fun talking with her
actually it was it was pretty profound -
I learned a few things
just like subconsciously but good up
there which is you want to know that
kind of stuff and so I see her again in
a couple weeks and then we will we'll
see how it goes so I used that raw
machine that you saw in last month's
video and girlfriend over there was like
did you do interval training I was like
no I'm just trying to survive because
I've never used it before I think I
survive I hurt though [ __ ] I'm trying
to be a professional we must be
professional
it's just casting spells on me spells I
just over there all right good girl
right here will actually frame up with
gypsy so I had a dream last night it was
kind of a weird dream to me because I
don't play sports I didn't play sports
in high school either okay gypsies gone
she doesn't care about this anymore and
so I am in high school in this dream I'm
a high school student in this high
school I've never seen before in my life
and the basketball coach sees something
in me and he's like he'd be great for
basketball I'm gonna take you under my
wing and whatnot I was like okay and so
I don't know how much time it was but I
guess I'm good at basketball now so the
big game is happening it's the cliche
thing that you've seen in movies where
the main character of the supporting
character needs to they need to leave
the game to do something more important
the coach gets mad so I had to leave
this game because I had uploaded a
YouTube video because I guess I still
have my YouTube channel and in the title
of that video was a spoiler for
something and I was like oh my gosh
change right now so I leave this
ever-important high school game that's
good of course change my life forever
because that's how important high school
basketball games are and I went home and
I changed the title narrowly escaping a
tragic fate bestowed on all my followers
and and then after that the dream
switched tracks completely because
that's our dreams are like you never
really notice the splice now you've is
in another place and you just don't
think anything of it
so now I'm at the Comedy Store which is
a comedy club
in Los Angeles and they're shutting down
so I'm there with Mark Ellis and we're
helping them pack up and clean up the
Comedy Store because it's gonna go away
and he's bought by someone else and it's
gonna be turned into who knows what
so that was my dream or those were my
dreams that were linked together as one
long dream welcome to my mind all right
now I gotta do a video on this detective
Pikachu trailer but thank you for
humoring my dream my neo hot toy came in
actually came in a couple weeks ago I
probably should have opened it then the
quality check it but I've been busy with
Vanessa's move so now I'm gonna open it
and that is Keanu he's gonna [ __ ] some
folks so the [ __ ] thing is I had to take
his head off to get the rapper stuff out
and that was shirt it's folding in so I
had to get this thing from a Captain
America Winter Soldier set that goes in
there and safely gets the shirt out from
being tucked so it's kind of obnoxious
wish this one had one with it ah [ __ ]
finally there was a lot of cursing and
sweat and stress off-camera but his
video so it's worthy so the tough thing
about neo is that he has so many iconic
poses but I really like this one this is
just very matrix II you know so that's
how I'm gonna pose him in the case and
now Neos at home with all of his guns
next to Punisher and daredevil and
Gandalf and old trophies that I've had
since I was a kid all right I'm
organizing the nerd room so before
before organization happens it has to
look like how and yes I'm listening to
the Metal Gear Solid 3 Fame while I'm
organizing my god look at all this stuff
it looks worse before it's one of the
Great's of all time one of the greatest
intros to a game of all time
why isn't there a Metroid movie it's
like what we're in the era of Hollywood
wanting to make strong female characters
there is it's like think Ripley from
aliens with an Ironman suit and she's a
bounty hunter like why hasn't that
happened yet I finally pulled the
trigger and Fire Emblem radiant dawn
I've been eyeballing this thing for ever
and a bigger now is the time so so far
no regrets Vanessa just got home we were
gonna lay down relax she was gonna go to
sleep for the night and I was gonna are
you there with her until she does but
the x-men trailer x-men Dark Phoenix
just dropped so essentially I gotta get
to work
it's still gonna lay down with her for a
bit does that all get to work 2:30
uploading my video internet went out
don't know why end of the month we're
gonna go full dish so that's it that was
my February so after people apparently
liked January for February I filmed a
lot of stuff I kinda would probably went
overboard on it
the vanessa was like March is gonna be
like 10 minutes long so I think it'll be
10 minutes long but who knows I'll just
film when I film edit would I edit and
March will come soon enough so thank you
again for being thoroughly entertained
if not mildly entertained with my very
boring and ordinary life so curious part
1 or part 2 February part 1 February
part 2 which one did you like more
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]